What lurks beneath the planet Jupiter's cloud cover?
Scientists hope to find out when NASA's Juno spacecraft...
...begins its one-year orbit of the massive planet.
Juno Project Manager, Jan Chodas.
So, here I have a model of the Juno Spacecraft.
The core structure contains our propulsion tanks...
...and most of the instruments are mounted on the forward and aft decks.
But obviously, the dominant feature here are the large solar arrays.
Juno's wings are covered in solar cells.
And the craft will rely on solar energy as it spins through space for the next five years.
At its closest approach to Jupiter,...
...Juno will be about 5,000 kilometers above the cloud tops...
...and it will dip down below the planet's dangerous radiation belts.
Juno will spend a year in polar orbit...
...and its eight instruments will study Jupiter's magnetic and gravity fields,...
...as well as the composition of the planet's atmosphere and core.
NASA scientists say this information will help them answer key questions about the way Jupiter...
...and the solar system evolved.
Chodas uses an animation to explain the beginning of Juno's 640-million-kilometer track...
...from NASA's Kennedy Space Center to the colossal planet.
Shortly after launch, about five minutes, we start the solar array deploy sequence.
There go the arrays.
It should take probably about one to three minutes to get the arrays out.
And then, if we are left at an attitude that is not directly sun-pointed,...
...we will turn to within 20 degrees of the sun...
...to illuminate the arrays and start recharging the battery.
And that will be putting us on our way to Jupiter...
...and possibly bringing us closer to a better understanding of the universe,...
...once Juno reaches Jupiter in 2016.
Susan Presto, VOA News.